bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 23 février
les agriculteurs ont ils raison d'être
en colère ils manifestent en tout cas
depuis que la municipalité écologistes
de lyon propose aux écoliers un menu
sans viande
de quoi accélérer le service pour mieux
se plier aux exigences du nouveau
protocole sanitaire contre le coc vide
selon le maire grégory douce et que ce
choix soit idéologique secteur élitiste
ou bien encore sanitaire la majorité en
tous cas se déchirent sur le sujet
emmanuel macron prône lui un rebelle la
complète d'alimentation
en italie un doux parfum de liberté
souffle à nouveau sur la capitale
lombarde il ya tout juste un an jour
pour jour au milan était la première
métropoles d'europe frappés par le virus
si la pandémie sévit toujours la vie
reprend peu à peu le dessus avec ses
gestes barrières restaurants et
commerces dans l'essentiel ont rouvert
leurs portes jusqu'à 18 heures voire 22
heures depuis le 1er février
outre-atlantique c'est un triste record
un an après le premier décès confirmés
les états unis dépassent le seuil des
500 milles morts liés à la pandémie de
loin le bilan le plus élevé au moins je
g et déchirant par joe biden le
locataire de la maison blanche a ordonné
la mise en berne des drapeaux sur
l'ensemble des bâtiments fédéraux
[Musique]
nous avons développé ces titres
l'actualité marquée par la mort de deux
adolescents lors de rixes ces dernières
24 heures dans l'essonne
on a pris ce soir qu'un adolescent avait
été tué à boussy saint antoine et un
autre blessé à la gorge dans ces
violences selon des sources policières
six interpellations ont eu lieu
un drame qui intervient au lendemain du
décès dans ce même département d'une
collégienne tuer cette fois d'un coup de
couteau dans le ventre
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
la jeune fille de 14 ans est interposé
lors d'une rixe entre deux bandes
rivales hier après midi vers 15 heures
il s'agirait de jeunes de saint chéron
et de dourdan elle est décédée de ses
blessures la nuit dernière à l'hôpital
trois mineurs ont été interpellés trois
autres se sont rendus à la police tous
ont été placés en garde à vue
un choc bien évidemment pour les
habitants de la ville c'était un peu le
fil entre les personnes de saint chéron
et se tordant donc il ya des personnes
de 12 ans qui sont venus à saint chéron
en bande apparemment et donc la
gestuelle a essayé de
de les séparer tout ça mais
et du coup il l'aurait menacée donc l
agresseur et
au final bas comme elle a persisté à
vouloir les séparer
la panne est inquiète un peu les
violences qui yahoo
le soir même de schorre on a peur de
champion des poids à une certaine heure
ici ça va à peu près mais il ya des
quartiers chauds un peu plus haut là
c'est vraiment l'horreur vraiment
l'horreur quand on pense que quand on
pense que ces jeunes ne se bagarrer à ce
point là surtout qu'ils étaient à la
porte
d'après ce que j'ai entendu à la radio
mais était à la porte
et puis s'en va entre des gamins de
dourdan et de saint chéron et maryse ont
eu des altercations fille la gamine a
voulu peut-être intervenir
et puis dans la rixe est telle qu après
le coup de couteau alors il se demande
pourquoi que tous ces jeunes ont des
couteaux sur la procureure de la
république d'evry donner une conférence
de presse cet après-midi écouter les
investigations mettait en évidence que
les six mineurs placés en garde à vue
avait pris les transports en commun pour
venir en découdre à saint chéron
dans un contexte de rivalités entre
bandes
les premières auditions permettait de
retrouver l'armé du crime
il s'agissait d'un opinel l'un des
mineurs admettez son application dans le
coup mortel porté à la victime
il est déjà connu pour deux infractions
sans lien avec des faits de violence les
qualifications retenues sont les
suivantes meurtres sur mineurs de 15 ans
violences aggravées sur mineur de 15 ans
en réunion et avec préméditation
participation à un groupement en vue de
commettre des violences non assistance à
personne en danger sur mineur de 15 ans
la polémique ne cesse d'enfler au sujet
du menu sans viande servie depuis
aujourd'hui dans les cantines scolaires
lyonnaise parallèlement au rejet de
cette décision de la ville par les
agriculteurs à une partie des parents
d'élèves
la majorité elle même se déchirent les
explications avec nicolas petit retirez
la viande des assiettes des élèves
julien de normandie n'y est pas vraiment
favorable
ce mardi le ministre de l'agriculture a
parlé de honte concernant la décision de
grégory douce et le maire europe
ecologie les verts de lyon qui peut
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui dans les
cantines de la république on arrête de
servir de la viande tous les jours de la
semaine
évidemment moi je ne le comprends pas
mais comme beaucoup beaucoup de parents
d'élèves
il y a une position qui est une posture
d'une municipalité europe ecologie les
verts qui consiste à arrêter de servir
de la viande à nos enfants
et c'est aberrant d'un point de vue
nutritionnel et c'est une honte d'un
point de vue social si cette position
est partagée par le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin qui samedi
avait été le premier membre du
gouvernement a dénoncé une idéologie
scandaleuse et une politique moraliste
et élitiste des verts qui exclut les
classes populaires
ce n'est en revanche pas le cas de la
ministre de la transition écologique
lundi barbara pompili a regretté un
débat préhistorique
je regrette beaucoup que sur ce sujet on
retombe dans un débat préhistorique et
des clichés éculés du type
l'alimentation végétarienne serait une
alimentation déséquilibrée
alors qu'on sait que la viande peut être
remplacé par du poisson des oeufs des
légumineuses qui apporte toutes les
protéines nécessaires
malgré ces renvois de balle successifs
et ses divergences importantes julien de
normandie à ce mardi réfuté toute
cacophonie au sein du gouvernement
le maire de lyon qui explique le choix
d'un menu unique sans viande par le
nouveau protocole sanitaire et la
nécessité de fluidifier le service à la
cantine pourrait avoir du mal à apaiser
les tensions
parallèlement à la fronde des
agriculteurs qui ont manifesté lundi
dans la métropole rhodanienne et des
parents d'élèves ont décidé de déposer
une requête en référé devant le tribune
administratif de lyon il demande un
minimum de menus avec de la viande dans
la semaine alors les agriculteurs
ont-ils eu raison d'être en colère à
l'état où les élus doivent s'y mettre
leur grain de sel dans le menu à la
cantine c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes avec et laurent courtois
président de la section bovine de la
fdsea du rhône et l'oni vieille
blanchard présidente de l'association
vérité rienne de france bonsoir à tous
les deux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france adore ce qui était
au départ une mesure où le précise quand
même destinée il y est surtout à la
crise sanitaire devient débat jugé
préhistorique 1 par la ministre de la
transition écologique barbara pompili
des repas unique sans viande
votre réaction laurent courtois écoutez
notre réaction c'est le maire de lyon a
dépassé les limites
c'est à dire que la loi de 2011 ôtez
doit mettre en évidence quatre points
sur 20 avec de la viande non achi que ça
soit style de feu de veau aux moutons
dans les repas de la cantine scolaire
donc monsieur le maire de rester ne
respectent pas leur pardon ils ne
respectent pas la loi c'est à dire que
dit la loi pour bien nous éclairer
laurent courtois parce que peut-être que
nos téléspectateurs et d'ailleurs
moi-même eu ignore ce qu'il ya dans la
loi concernant en tout cas les les menus
de cantine scolaire
la loi oblige de mettre quatre points
sur 20 de viande non h et en boeuf vous
et moutons sans compter la viande hachée
alors elodie vieille blanchard l'état ne
respecteraient pas la loi c'est ce que
vous avez envie de retenir de cette
polémique
alors non pas du tout en fait monsieur
courtois fait référence à un arrêté de
2011 mais entre temps la loi et galim en
fait à remplacer s'est arrêté
et aujourd'hui en fait ce que dit la loi
c'est que il est obligatoire de servir
au moins une fois par semaine une
options végétariennes donc ça peut être
tous les jours de la semaine
donc il n'ya pas de problème du point de
vue de la loi pas du tout alors la
question de fond finalement parce que
peut-être que je le répète à une partie
nos téléspectateurs ignorait tout
simplement qu'ils avaient ce genre
d'injonction dans la loi mais de la
viande
oui ou non revient à se poser peut-être
la question à ce que le législateur et a
fortiori l'état peut-il mettre son grain
de sel dans les menus des cantines est
ce que finalement ce ne sont pas aux
parents de décider
laurent courtois je dirais c'est un peu
tout le monde
il en va de la vie de nos territoires
parce que manger que de que du végétal
importés je dirais n'est pas au niveau
carbone quelque chose de très de très
bien
c'est à dire vous dit en gros on ne sait
pas dire avant cet indice sur le
territoire proche de lyon que ça sur les
monts du beaujolais des monts du
lyonnais
on ne peut rien faire d'autre que de
l'élevage donc nous avons des pv qui
captent le carbone on est en plein dans
l'actualité
et c'est le sait la vie de l or l audi
vieille blanchard up pour vous c'est un
discours qui est audible de la part de
notre ami agriculteur il faut aussi
tenir compte du territoire des
agriculteurs
dans ces affaires de menus de cantine où
c'est quelque chose finalement à écarter
pour vous et prioriser d'autres
impératifs et je crois que déjà il faut
replacer un petit peu le contexte c'est
à dire que là on est dans un cadre de
gestion de crise avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée des enfants qui
doivent être à une distance physique
d'au moins deux mètres donc c'est dans
ce contexte là en fait que le maire de
lyon dans un contexte où il ya toujours
eu deux menus un menu sans viande un
menu avec viande le menu sans viande
étant choisie par 50 % des usagers a
choisi d'imposer un menu unique pour
seulement cette semaine donc c'est un
contexte vraiment très spécifiques
par ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il ya toute
une démarche en fait de d'écologisation
des menus dans les cantines lyonnaises
je sais que la municipalité de lyon a
rencontré les acteurs des filières
locales y compris les acteurs de la
filière bovine
donc je pense que ça ne s'est pas tout à
fait approprié ici de réagir à ce sujet
là je pense que les éleveurs manifestent
une détresse mais il ya aussi une
expression un peu opportuniste par
rapport à la situation actuelle qui est
vraiment un sujet de gestion de crise
voilà il y avait deux menus ils ont
choisi le menu le plus inclusive c'est à
dire qui convient à 100 % des usagers
c'est une décision logique de bon sens
c'est une décision qui avait été prise
par monsieur collomb il ya l'année
dernière en fait au mois de mai dans le
même contexte et qui n'avait pas du tout
susciter toutes les réactions que ça
suscite aujourd'hui
alors justement ça suscite des réactions
peut-être parce que avec ce que vous
nous avez expliqué dans votre première
partie il ya peut-être aussi une
démarche écologique là dedans on parle
de la crise sanitaire mais ce n'est
peut-être pas le fond du problème c'est
votre avis en tout cas laurent courtois
vous avez le sentiment aujourd'hui qu'on
vous joue un mauvais tour sans en
afficher clairement les contours
oui tout est fait on connaît les ide les
idéologies du maire de lyon
on comprend pas pourquoi lyon n'arrive
pas à mettre des repas avec de la viande
et que tout les 36000 communes en france
les autres communes se débrouille très
bien mettre de la viande même en temps
de crise
pour nous c'est un faux débat l'écho
vide c'est une fois s'excuser en tout
cas oui pour nous éleveurs oui c'est une
fausse excuse alors en tout cas je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur quelques
réactions parce que ce débat a suscité
beaucoup de prises de parole entre hier
et aujourd'hui
celle notamment du député la république
en marge de l'indre françois jolivet
écouter ils n'en veulent plus il rêve
d'un monde où la viande n'existe plus il
rêve d'imposer leur idéologie
minoritaires d'extract rice de nos
valeurs communes
dans le sillage de leurs dogmes la fin
de l'élevage français
pour moi c'est non alors l audi vieille
blanchard ils ce sont évidemment les
écologistes vous êtes président de
l'association végétarienne de france est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic de françois jolivet en gros
on veut éliminer la viande de ce monde
et notamment pour commencer par les
mimiques continue de nos écoliers
en fait il ya un consensus international
à la fois sur les questions d'écologie
et sur les questions de santé donc en
france le haut conseil de santé publique
lan 16 recommande de réduire assez
fortement la consommation de protéines
animales notamment dans les cantines il
ya aussi évidemment tous les enjeux
écologiques que ce soit des enjeux
climatiques des enjeux liés à la
biodiversité
en fait tous les scénarios aujourd'hui
de transition agricole et écologique que
revendique une forte très forte
décroissance de la consommation de
protéines animales donc ça n'est pas du
tout un enjeu partisan c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est consensuelle
je pense que même les acteurs de
l'élevage avec lesquels on échange se
rendent compte qu'ils à une nécessaire
transition amorcée donc là dessus je
pense que ce serait beaucoup plus
intelligent en fait à la fois de la part
de l'état et de la part des
représentants de l'élevage de réfléchir
à cette transition et de voir comment on
peut envisager une transition sur les
territoires de l'emploi pour un maintien
de la ruralité pour un maintien
justement de de l'emploi plutôt que de
s'opposer à ces transitions qui sont
inéluctables mais encore une fois je
crois que ça n'est même pas le sujet ici
puisque c'est vraiment un sujet à très
court terme de gestion du protocole
sanitaire ça effectivement elodie
vieille blanchard c voilà ce qu'on
voudrait peut-être pas nous faire croire
parce que c'est qu'avant c'était
l'objectif officiel c'était ce lien avec
la crise sanitaire mais vous voyez bien
que le débat va au delà puisque vous le
dites vous même il ya une transition qui
va se mettre en place sous mais aussi
vous proposer d'écouter eric zemmour un
polémiste chez nos confrères de ces news
mais essayez c'est évidemment également
sur son avis sur la question côté il y a
deux raisons qui poussent les maires à
faire des menus sans viande
la présence d'une population musulmane
et l'idéologie écolo vegan évidemment
eric zemmour en lui il n'y croit pas du
tout à ce lien avec la crise sanitaire
on est dit il dans l'idéologie en
l'occurrence écolo vegan laurent
courtois c'est aussi votre avis où il
pousse un peu trop peut-être eric
zemmour sur ce thème
on connaît eric zemmour pour ses pour
ses phrases mais je voudrais revenir au
niveau de l'agronomie humour si on
passait tout en végétal en france on
serait déjà des honoraires pour la
dépendance alimentaire et pour avoir du
végétal il faut de la matière organique
animal on a on a eu des commandes hier
des je perds mes mots excusez moi on
sait que sansan matières organiques
animales le végétal pouces en bien
moindre quantité donc en france on ne
peut pas produire assez de végétale pour
nourrir tout le monde j'irai si on
arrêtait l'animal elodie vieille
blanchard votre réponse il ya beaucoup
de monde c'est un sujet qui est tout à
fait contestable mais je crois que c'est
même pas la question ici fin on n'est
pas en train de parler d'un monde où il
ya plus doux d'élevage on est en train
de parler d'un monde où il ya un peu
moins d'élevage en particulier en france
où on mange deux fois plus de viande
qu'à l'échelle de la planète
on dépend beaucoup des importations de
protéine végétale pour nourrir les
animaux qu'on consomme en france il
s'agit notamment de l'importation de
soja qui vient massivement de la région
de l'ex amazonie et donc on n'est
vraiment pas dans ce sujet là donc ça me
semble tout à fait erroné de mettre en
avant ce genre de
deux sujets alors inconscient en tout
cas du sujet sensible du côté des
agriculteurs emmanuel macron s'est
emparé également du débat aujourd'hui à
lors d'une visite en côte d'or je vous
propose d'écouter le président de la
république
le changement ne peut se faire du jour
au lendemain
nous sommes engagés collectivement dans
une très grande transition
il faut de tout remettre des
légumineuses avoir aussi une viande de
qualité rester dans un modèle complet
d'alimentation voilà dupont pas d'y
étendre son cas de ce débat lié à la
crise sanitaire
il s'empare du débat de fond le chef de
l'état laurent courtois ça vous rassure
d'entendre ces propos plutôt apaisant du
chef de l'état bien sûr c'est son rôle
d'apaiser les tensions mais je dirais
que quand même là la viande rouge est
important pour un enfant de kate en
primaire on sait que le que le faire
végétales et mal assimilée par ses
enfants il faut du du cher qui viennent
de là de la viande rouge en effet alors
elodie veille blanchard voilà ce côté
apaisant il faut de tout y compris des
légumineuses en gros le chef de l'état
qui essaie de ne fâcher personne votre
réaction
mais ici on est quand même en train de
parler sud on est en train de parler de
quatre repas sur quatorze pendant une
période de sept semaines
donc évidemment que c'est tout à fait
possible que les enfants se passe de
viande pendant quatre repas pendant
cette semaine c'est à dire qu'on envoie
tué repas la position scientifique
unanimes c'est qu' il n'y a pas du tout
besoin de viande ni d'ailleurs de
poisson pour être en bonne santé
et d'ailleurs je reprends les propos du
professeur mario ticket le président du
comité d'experts spécialisés nutrition
de la ne cesse donc la référence
nationale sur le sujet selon lequel les
enfants végétariens ont globalement un
meilleur état nutritionnel que les
enfants nivore donc il ya vraiment pas
de problème sur sur le sujet je crois
que le vrai problème et on s'en rend
bien compte c'est que on a des filières
d'élevage qui sont en détresse qui se
sentent menacés par la montée actuelle
des de la prise de conscience sur les
enjeux écologiques sur les enjeux
éthiques
mais je crois que la réponse à apporter
à ça c'est pas de la part des cantines
de soutenir des filières en crise ce
n'est pas le rôle des cantines en fait
la bonne réponse à mon sens c'est de
réfléchir à des transitions au niveau
des territoires au niveau du modèle
agricole et ça ça doit se faire
évidemment avec les filières d'élevage
mais on doit pas s'opposer en fait à des
transitions qui sont inéluctables et qui
vont dans le bon sens que ce soit pour
la santé publique pour l'écologie ou
bien évidemment pour pour l'éthique
laurent courtois votre réponse parce que
c'est vrai que ce n'est peut-être pas
aux comptines de gérer ce genre de
situation vous répondez quoi elodie
vieille blanchard oui tout à fait c'est
pas le rôle des cantines mais bon c'est
quand même un message qu'on envoie à la
population dans le sens où la la la
viande est une mauvaise pour le club
pour la santé ce qui n'est pas le cas
mais je voulais je voudrais rebondir sur
la mairie de lyon qui nous a proposé en
effet de de prendre contact avec nous
pour l'heure pour le la reprise de
l'école au mois d'avril
au bout de ces sept semaines pour
travailler avec nous pour fournir de la
viande locale donc on emboîte le pas en
disant qu'on y est très bien le mode
afin elodie vieille blanchard pour vous
on l'a compris et vous vous dites oui il
se débat lié à la crise sanitaire très
bien mais il faudrait aller plus loin
avec plus de menus végétariens à l'école
ce serait une bonne chose bien sûr va
déjà nous on se réjouit que ce débat
émerge parce qu'en fait on a entendu de
la part des représentants de l'état des
arguments complètement erronée et éculés
donc ça nous permet
ramener un certain nombre de vérités sur
la santé sur l'écologie donc ça c'est
très bien
et évidemment que c'est une bonne
occasion de poser aussi cette nécessaire
transition de nos modèles agricoles et
alimentaires donc on est très content de
cette cette occasion pour merci beaucoup
à tous les deux et l'audi vieille
blanchard laurent courtois d'avoir
accepté ce débat en direct sur rt france
le maire de perros guirec dans les côtes
d'armor souhaite installer un centre de
vaccination dans sa ville où un quart de
la population est âgée de plus de 75 ans
impossible selon l'état qui impose une
structure pour au moins cent mille
habitants une règle qui peut poser
problème aux personnes ayant des
difficultés à se déplacer en attendant
dans cette ville seuls les ehpad et des
résidences spécialisées sont
prioritaires mais l'édile espère
toujours faire entendre sa cause renault
parquet avec françois xavier lambert les
vaccinations s'enchaînent à un rythme
effréné dans la salle principale de
cette résidence pour seniors de perros
guirec
l'établissement organise en deux étapes
l'immunisation de ses 93 résidents après
avoir reçu leur première injection la
plupart se disent soulagés on devait
faire un otage et maintenant
on est à plein d'entrain mais on est
content de ta part enfin rue pour
organiser cette journée le conseil
départemental a mise à disposition à
jean médecin ou infirmier une
organisation qui implique une logistique
importante pendant un mois près de 1000
personnes prioritaires pourraient être
vaccinés pour la directrice de cette
résidence il s'agit d'une réussite
malgré les nombreuses contraintes
administratives depuis le 19 janvier
effectivement nous sommes sur la partie
administrative qui a été lourde
nous avons bien sûr suivi les conseils
du des protocoles du conseil
départemental mais de la rs aujourd'hui
en fait c'était pour nous facile ce tout
sept jours d'herve administrative nous a
permis de faciliter la vie une
satisfaction partagée par le maire de la
ville et reviennent les ondes énonce les
règles édictées par l'état qui ne
permettent l'installation dans centres
de vaccination qu'à partir de cent mille
habitants
l'édile espère toujours obtenir gain de
cause alors que la structure la plus
proche se situe à lannion à 12 km de
perros guirec une difficulté pour des
personnes âgées qui peine déjà à obtenir
un rendez vous pour se faire vacciner
ça fait la démonstration qu'à centres de
vaccination de proximité
on peut le réaliser sans problème
le dans les salons de cette résidence
seniors avec les deux médecins des
infirmiers enfin tout le protocole est
parfaitement respectée et ça permet de
vacciner une centaine de personnes très
facilement et laissant aucun problème
donc ça la démonstration qu'un centre de
vaccination de proximité ouvert aux
personnes donc cibler tout à fait
faisable à perros guirec en cas d'accord
avec l'état le maire de la commune va
installer le centre de vaccination dans
cette salle municipale
en attendant un possible assouplissement
des règles
le préfet a assuré dans la presse que
les structures de vaccination allait se
développer d'ici la fin du mois
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous partirons en italie et plus
précisément dans la capitale lombarde il
est tout juste un an milan était la
première métropoles d'europe frappée par
le virus et les restrictions la vie
reprend peu à peu ses droits là bas et
puis direction les états unis avec un
triste record
on nous le seuil des 5000 morts liés à
la pandémie est dépassé de loin le bilan
le plus élevé au monde juge et déchirant
1 par joe biden
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fall ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les cafards s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont la des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous s'il arrive quelque
chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent là en soi vient des
lignes aujourd'hui une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les accords d'abraham changer
l'équilibré stratégique pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe preuve
j'étais le seul à pouvoir créer
induction d'une paix durable grâce à ses
relations différentes avec tous les
acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez la vie semble
revenir à la normale à milan en italie
fin janvier on s'en souvient la
lombardie dont milan et la métropole est
passé en zone jaune depuis les musées
ont rouvert leurs portes au public la
cathédrale aussi que vous voyez sur ces
images on reçoit des visiteurs bars et
restaurants sont également ouverts dans
la journée jusqu'à 18 heures ensuite les
milanais peuvent au moins prolonger leur
soirée chez eux le couvre-feu et tente à
22h et pour en parler mais nous sommes
en direct avec umberto giovannini
médecins chirurgiens en direct donc
l'italie à milan précisément bonsoir
umberto giovannini merci d'être avec
nous pour parler de cette situation on
lambardi donc un nom un jour bonjour on
imagine que c'est une délivrance réel ce
retour à la vie normale mais aussi
symboliques pour aller les milanais
oui s'il retour mais j'en ai encore
quand même très prudent d'abord ceux qui
suivaient la politique italienne on sait
qu'il ya juste tout frais du changement
de gouvernement et il ya des nouvelles
réflexions qui sont prévus donc la lutte
arl dé sortir des couleurs jaune rouge
et orange qui ont été adoptées jusqu'à
maintenant pour retourner en couleur
orange pour tous les résultats région
mais effectivement pour le moment à
milan on sent qu'un une ère de renouveau
aussi la météo est déjà ça parce qu'on a
des températures très douces et un
soleil qui éclaire tous les jours et les
gens ils auraient pris goût à vivre on
fera en sorte iran répondent aller au
restaurant
donc ça change un peu les habitudes
parce que auparavant les restaurants ce
qui est surtout là pérol soir mais là on
fait restaurant et on prolonge la
période jusqu'à 18 heures donc comme
changer les habitudes milanaise
effectivement après les périodes de
ternes d
née dernière comme ici c'était des
ambulances qui creuse et la nuit et qui
se met tout le temps et de la tristesse
dans les yeux des gens là on sent un
changement la politique aussi des bacs
scène il en train de commencer à métro
opinions seront ont commencé à vacciner
toute la population âgée député 80 ans
tous les médecins qui travaillent à
l'hôpital ont été vaccinées par contre
il est un petit tôt limites parce que
nous les médecins libéraux
on est bien oubliée avec aussi les 64 65
qu'ils ont des vaccinations parce qu' on
attend toujours d'être vacciné et on est
un peu passé lui aux oubliettes
quelle est la stratégie italienne par ce
conseil chez nous c'est ce sont les plus
âgées les soignants aussi c'est bon
c'est pas exactement la même chose de
une distinction entre les différents
soignants nous c'était d'abord on soigne
les gens qui créent l'hôpital donc on a
même soigné les études de médecine
maloubier tous les médecins libéraux
donc après on a vacciné les médecins de
famille mais tous les médecins libéraux
qui traînaient des cliniques privées
ils ont été oubliés de la vaccination il
faut aussi savoir qu'il n'ya eu un
centre à la médecine libérale en italien
en français ce que la médecine libérale
en france et c'est quand même
il y à l'état donc les remboursements de
l'état de la médecine libérale en italie
il est complètement libre donc si le
passé en équipe et à l'assurance
mais nous les médecins qui n'ont kimono
qui nous avons pas d'affiliation avec
les publics
on est encore un talent d'être vacciné
il ya quelques jeunes qui auraient fait
vacciner mais parce qu'il a dit maxime
baca sionneau l'hôpital mais les autres
ont été oubliés et au niveau de la
population donc à recommencer avec les
personnels soignants et après on a connu
un séminaire soigner les personnes plus
âgées les plus âgés de 80 ans la contrée
là aussi les polémiques parce qu'elle
est ce 104 75 ans il sort pas trop car
ils vont être vaccinés
donc il ya un vaccination qui a commencé
pour la fonction publique avec les moins
de 55 ans avec les actionnaires
stratégiques alors on le disait un même
si tout n'est pas rouvert en école pas
complètement les commerçants et sociales
jusqu'à 18 heures
les restaurants rouvrir également
vous en tant que médecin même si on l'a
entendu votre message de prudence
vous avez quand même le sentiment que le
pire est derrière vous l'art les pires
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui on maîtrise
mieux la pathologie de kobe dont ces
fiers du dépistage est plus limpide
on teste beaucoup plus donc on a moins
des cas graves on a moins l'impression
que les real sont saturés après c'est
sûr qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
deuxième une troisième bague là il ya
une quinzaine dans la banlieue milanaise
il ya une classe terre des nouveaux kobe
de personnes anglaise mais du coup là on
réagit très vite par rapport à l'année
dernière on ferme la ville et les
militaires qui sont sur place et c'est
où les tâches les clusters très
rapidement après je vous dis célia
ménages mais aussi les soucis
économiques parce qu'il part pour la
france en moins de conneries swindell
les aider on est témoin d'un le rasage
ou moins ponctuels donc on commence à
parler aussi des suicides à cause de la
détresse économique
donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours saisi
un exercice d'équilibré à un autre
ne laissez pas la vague des copies de
submerger les hôpitaux mais de l'autre
côté aussi permettre aux gens à
retrouver l'espoir de retrouver aussi
une dynamique économique il ne faut pas
oublier la la semaine dernière à milan
c'était la fashion week
mais la tâche en lui que dès cette année
c'était une désert alors que jusqu'à
l'année même l'année dernière qui
s'était jusque là entre copines à me
poser les trouver un taxi et pas aimé
trouver et 00h01 lit d'hôtel elle
possible de trouver une place au resto
là c'était complètement opposées c'est
vrai qu'ils ont envie de retrouver quand
même une certaine l'espoir et commencer
à regarder le futur plutôt que le passé
justement on le rappelle quand même ce
thème bilan 27 mille morts pour la seule
lombardi aujourd'hui avec ses
restaurants qui rouvre on imagine vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs qu'il le fait
plutôt bon en italie vous avez le
sentiment voilà que c'est le retour à la
vie que les italiens se jette dans ses
possibilités de divertissement au
contraire il ya une forme de
traumatismes qui invite à la retenue
mais c'est comme tout il ya plusieurs
attitudes il ya celles qui
on était traumatisée terrorisés par les
corridas qui sont encore très floues
ils ont peur ils restent très interne et
mêmes ans ils sont complices très
agressif vis-à-vis des auteurs donc
qu'il n'accepte pas qu'elles j'envie
sortir ni rien et après il ya une couche
de la population l inverse qui étaient
enfermés pendant si longtemps et qui
finalement mais non hélas des noix envie
d'aider à vivre encore il ya une
polémique parce qu'il ya les derbys qui
était jouée d'image effectivement lilas
rassemblement des 10000 personnes devant
les stades de foot
il a aussi sa fille pauline presque à l
inverse ça aussi ça fait une cour
cafouillage juste qu'il ya une semaine
c'était prévu que les pistes des ski
réouvre et 12h20 regret sur les
gouvernements à signer l'arrêt comme
quoi les pistes des ski ne pouvait pas
trop berck donc clients parfois il ya
environ une cacophonie est une
contradiction de saas qui permet à dix
mille personnes des réserves a semblé
d'avant les stades mais d'un autre côté
on en fait les gens les 6e j'ai ce qui
est donc c'est vrai que ça les gens sont
très déstabilisée nous dans le rôle
médecine soit on doit leur expliquer
pourquoi il ya des choix et parfois
c'est des choix qui sont faits et pour
un compromis qui sont pas forcément que
médical mais ils sont aussi économiques
c'était à quoi umberto giovannini parce
qu'on voit on a vu la différence par
exemple très clair avec le royaume-uni
où il ya vraiment un plan très détaillé
un calendrier détaillé en tout cas une
stratégie très claire et la france qui a
pris le parti voilà de réagir aux
fonctions d des chiffres un parti pris
manifestement assumer on confine en
fonction des des éventuels chiffres en
italie c'est dû à quoi cette espèce de
confusion peut-être au changement du
gouvernement ou voilà on laisse tout
simplement venir on navigue à vue
mais il est un peu de tout ça il faut
dire que déjà l'attitude enitalie cdc
dévoué beaucoup plus par rapport à
l'état pur la fin j'ai travaillé
beaucoup au prince en france on a un
état qui se coupent beaucoup qui est
très protecteur qui bique
la feuille de route intel y en a une et
à qui est là pour supporter dans des
cirques une sas mais se voit les gens
s'unissent et la démo et je vous dis
mais ont des points de vue économique
les aides données en france c'était
beaucoup plus simple qu aider l'italie
l'italie les gens ici sont le
débrouiller avec leur épargne
mais si les pays qui a plus corsée perdu
privé d'europe mais il est aussi le plus
gros déficit public dont vous voyez
c'est un état où s'est déroulée ta il
m'a ternissent pas autant qu'en france
et après il ya aussi un lit aux
législations régionales sous la
politique de santé qui est beaucoup plus
libre par la france donc c'est moins
centralisée donc il y avait une science
qui sont centralisés
mais après sont relâchés à la sauce
locale donc ça aussi ça fait parfois des
frictions mais aussi à l'est les combats
politiques parce qu'il ya des certains
régions qui sont à droite du
gouvernement qui était populiste
gauchistes donc ça aussi parfois ça crée
des frictions et là on a les spa avec
ces nouveaux goûts world gouvernement
qui fédère un peu plus tout le tous les
clans politiques de la droite dans
l'extrême droite mais de la droite et
jusqu'à la gauche
donc on ne laisse pas au montana c'est
le père au delà de pouvoir d'avoir
quelque chose n'est plus harmonieux où
il ya moins d des frictions par exemple
des jeunes qui à droite un gouvernement
qu'à gauche donc ça c'est aussi ça peut
jouer notre fatigue et on a moins de
maîtrise mais le coc vide on a moins des
cas on commence à mieux vacciner et du
coup même on peut avoir une politique
plus nationale d'abord c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont les traits d'un visage et
peut-être qu'on va faire sauter une
histoire des couleurs par exemple mais
on va dessiner une couleur unique pour
tous là tout l'italie avec après mise
sur les classes terre qui vont être
considéré d'une rouge et merci beaucoup
matao giovannini médecin chirurgien nous
avoir partie parler de la situation en
italie et particulièrement en lombardie
un an jour pour jour après l'apparition
du virus et les premiers dons
confinement
à milan merci à vous aux etats unis
triste record le pays vient de franchir
le cap des 500 milles morts liés aux
kovy de 19,1 bilan tellement lourd que
joe biden
unis a pris la parole hier soir pour
s'adresser à la nation selon le
président américain la pandémie a causé
la mort de davantage d'américains en
trois guerres réuni mes disques et fit
un demi million de morts et un hommage
national ce lundi joe biden a observé
une minute de silence devant la maison
blanche accompagné de sa vice-présidente
kamala harris
il a symboliquement commémorer les cinq
cent mille décès américains duo kobe de
19 avec notamment cinq cents bougies
placées sur le balcon et les marches de
la résidence officielle
le chef d'état démocrate a ordonné la
mise en berne des drapeaux américains
sur tous les bâtiments fédéraux pour les
cinq prochains jours pays le plus touché
au monde par la pandémie
les etats-unis ont perdu l'équivalent de
la totalité de la population de l'île de
malte
each day a aussi vu ce mois encore même
pas que sur chaque jour je reçois une
petite carte dans la poche j'ai avec moi
mon emploi du temps
elle indique le nombre d'américains qui
ont été touchés ou qui sont morts du
côté de 19
aujourd'hui nous marquons une étape
vraiment sinistre et déchirante 500000
71 morts c'est plus d'américains qui
sont morts en un an dans cette pandémie
que dans la première guerre mondiale
la seconde guerre mondiale et la guerre
du vietnam réuni ses plus de vies
perdues à cause de ce virus que dans
n'importe quelle autre nation sur terre
mais alors que nous reconnaissons
l'ampleur de cette mort massive en
amérique
souvenez-vous de chaque personne et de
la vie qu'elle a vécu un bilan humain
tragique mais une note d'espoir tout de
même avec une baisse des nouveaux cas et
de la moyenne hebdomadaire des morts ces
dernières semaines selon les autorités
sanitaires du pays
cette amélioration est constante par
rapport au mois de janvier
nous voyons une baisse continue des cas
de kobe de 10
depuis cinq semaines avec des infections
10 millions de 69% depuis un pic atteint
le 11 janvier pour le moment plus de 61
millions de personnes ont reçu une
première dose du vaccin contre le
coronavirus aux états unis le pays reste
leader mondial en la matière devant la
chine ou encore le royaume uni objectif
des autorités américaines obtenir les
doses nécessaires pour vacciner
l'ensemble de la population d'ici fin
juillet sur la crise sanitaire avec
précision de calais maupin correspondant
d'arte et aux etats unis c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir à ce
stade
l'administration byden travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour renverser la
tendance avec le coville 19
nous avons tous entendu le discours
déchirant de joe biden la question est
de savoir qui arriveront ils
il y a eu beaucoup de chaos des vaccins
perdu des rendez-vous modifié il y à pas
mal de confusion mais si
l'administration byden réussi à changer
la donne rapidement s'ils réussissent à
maintenir le rythme d'un million de
vaccinations par jour
ce serait une grande victoire pour
l'administration byden les communiqués
récents de l'administration baden sont
tous d'un ton très posé ils ne font pas
de déclaration fracassante sur les
grands sujets il reste dans des
généralités avec lesquels quasiment tous
les américains sont d'accord ils ne
veulent pas courir de risques
c'est une approche prudente de la part
de la nouvelle administration à la
maison blanche
il essaie de se détacher de
l'administration trump mais en fin de
compte ce sont leurs actions qui nous
permettront de dire s'ils ont réussi ou
non les résultats seront leurs messages
s'ils n'obtiennent pas de résultat clair
alors on ne saura pas vraiment
malheureusement je ne pense pas que les
vaccins chinois et russes seront 10
ni bhl aux états unis dans un avenir
proche les médias américains n'ont de
cesse de discréditer et vaccins russes
et chinois on ne peut pas aux états unis
sur twitter ou sur facebook
remettre en question les vaccins
utilisés ici mais le scepticisme contre
les vaccins russe et chinois est très
fort certains vaccins peuvent être
questionné d'autres non c'est vraiment
deux poids deux mesures dans les médias
américains et cela montre le très grand
parti pris ceux qui critiquent les
vaccins de moderna outsiders sont
accusés d'être dans le couple autisme
leurs comptes sont clôturées le vaccin
russe est sans cesse contesté dans les
grands médias occidentaux
il essaie de mettre en place une
rhétorique géopolitique tout en ignorons
mettons en doute les grands succès du
vaccin russe le vaccin russe est très
efficace mais les médias américains
s'efforcent de remettre en question de
jeter le doute à tout prix c'est honteux
il y a beaucoup de frustration dans la
population américaine face au co vite 19
le confit de moins pour le manque
d'accès à des médicaments des vaccins
pour beaucoup de gens le problème est le
manque de cohérence au niveau du pays
les objectifs varient et le premier
confinement n'était pas un véritable
confinement nous n'avons encore jamais
eu de véritable confinement et il ya
encore beaucoup de confusion
actuellement le confinement a eu un
impact économique ce qui s'ajoute à la
situation au texas les coupures
d'électricité d'eau courante
les etats unis font face à une crise
majeure
le pays manque de cohérence il n'y a pas
de programme unique
il n'y a pas de marge dans certaines
infrastructures de base qui fonctionne
mal aux états unis de même que les
institutions il ya beaucoup de colère
contre le fait que le système de santé
américain et rendu les tests très très
cher
beaucoup d'américains n'ont pas d'accès
à la santé il n'y a pas de couverture
universelle aux etats-unis la crise du
coc vide a révélé de nombreux problèmes
posés par la structure même des états
unis
beaucoup de problèmes récurrents aux
états unis qu'il s'agisse de la santé
des infrastructures de la désunion des
programmes divergent au sein des
gouvernements
tout cela a été mise en lumière le coc
vide a exposé de nombreux problèmes de
la société américaine
beaucoup d'américains le comprennent et
les tensions la méfiance sont à des
niveaux très élevés on se rappelle du 6
janvier l'administration baden est
maintenant au pouvoir
mais le ressentiment l'attention et la
méfiance que ressent beaucoup
d'américains a été amplifiée par cette
crise selon moi campagne de vaccination
la semaine dernière une quinzaine de
députés se sont fait vacciner à
l'intérieur du parlement une violation
de la stratégie de vaccination selon le
président du comité scientifique
libanais de son côté la banque mondiale
pourrait suspendre ses financements et
son soutien à beyrouth les explications
de maxime hébert deuxième semaine de
vaccination au liban est déjà une
première polémique
seize députés se sont fait vacciner dans
l'enceinte du parlement ce mardi
problème ils sont accusés de ne pas
s'être enregistrés sur la plateforme en
ligne condition obligatoire pour avoir
accès au vaccin
ce qu'il s'est passé et inexcusables et
inacceptables
cela n'aurait jamais dû arriver et cela
ne doit pas se reproduire
même si je ne dis pas que cela ne se
reproduira pas ce qui est arrivé n'a
rien à voir avec le directeur de tels ou
tels centres de vaccination qui appelle
deux personnes et les laisse entrer
c'est une erreur qui est symbolique le
parlement est censé représenter le
peuple libanais
la banque mondiale principal bailleur de
fonds du liban à verser 34 millions de
dollars à beyrouth pour soutenir sa
lutte contre le coc u19 face à la
polémique elle menace désormais de
suspendre ses aides
les modalités de ces vaccinations ne
respecte pas le plan national décidé en
accord avec la banque mondiale
nous enregistrerons les violations des
conditions de vaccination établi sur
lesquels nous nous étions mis d'accord
afin d'assurer une vaccination juste et
équitable
si ces violations sont confirmées la
banque mondiale peut suspendre le
financement des vaccins et son soutien
au liban dans la lutte contre le coc vie
de 19
j'en appelle à la responsabilité de
chacun indépendamment de votre poste
inscrivez vous et attendez votre tour
une vague d'indignation déferle depuis
sur les réseaux sociaux
le hashtag nos as ta non au népotisme
est en tête des tendances sur twitter
cette affaire ajoute un peu plus à la
défiance d'une partie des libanais
envers leur classe politique dans un
pays rongé par la corruption
la première phase de vaccination est
censé être réservée au personnel médical
et aux personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans
inscrits sur la plateforme internet
pourtant un rapport de la croix rouge
libanaise la firme depuis le lancement
de la campagne 40% des centres de
vaccination ne respecterait pas les
mesures prévues et des groupes non
prioritaires ou des personnes non
inscrites ont été vaccinées au total dix
sept mille personnes ont déjà été
vaccinées au liban le pays de six
millions d'habitants recense 350 mille
cas de kovy 19 dont plus de 4000 décès
et on en bien cet échange assez
surprenant le premier ministre israélien
rapatrier une juive orthodoxe parties en
syrie contre eux deux bergers syriens
mais aussi des doses du vaccin rue
spoutnik v la russie s'est et poser en
médiatrice pour accompagner cet échange
entre la série il serait né ce n'est pas
la première fois manifestement les
détails en images
l'israélienne au centre de cet échange
est une juive de 25 ans elle aurait déjà
tenté de fuir son milieux orthodoxes à
plusieurs reprises notamment pour se
rendre dans la bande de gaza mais aussi
en jordanie
la jeune femme qui parle arabe a franchi
une frontière pourtant très surveillé
entre israël et la syrie
les habitants du village syriens l'ont
dénoncé aux autorités
elle a ensuite été arrêtés soupçonnés
d'espionnage par les services de
renseignements syriens les négociations
alors commencé entre benyamin nétanyahou
et vladimir poutine la russie dont les
relations avec la syrie sont amicales a
pu assurer la médiation en échange de
berger siri ont été libérés par l'état
hébreu
également soupçonné d'espionnage il
avait été capturé après leur entrée sur
un territoire contrôlé par l'armée
israélienne
israël a toujours fait et fera toujours
tout ce qui est en son pouvoir pour
ramener ses citoyens à la maison en plus
de cet échange
israël a également exigé des doses du
vaccin russe poutine iv selon la presse
israélienne il y en aurait pour plus
d'un million de dollars
ce n'est pas la première fois que moscou
joue le rôle de médiateur entre israël
et la syrie
en 2019 la dépouille de zacharie bommel
un soldat israélien tué au liban en 1982
a pu être rendus à israël
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la situation sanitaire en france fut
maire de dunkerque veut tout tenté avant
confinement local olivier veron est
attendu sur place demain pour annoncer
de nouvelles mesures et puis nous
parlerons de la stratégie du
gouvernement face aux variants aimé
en déplacement aujourd'hui en côte d'or
indique préférer régionaliser les
mesures à l'image des alpes-maritimes
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on est énervé
on a le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
majorque mâcon il passe un tour de
tracteur avec toutes mes campagnes il
faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise lorsque c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait ça au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris après
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restaurants
c'est pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout un questionnement
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidement
depuis des décennies il s'est imposé
comme la devise incontournable dans le
commerce international le dollar peut-il
être détrôné détrôner pas encore c'est
pas quelque chose d'à ce faire en lice
jo à ce que veut faire les chinois c'est
qu'ils veulent des de l'arizona j parce
que le dollar à des folies qui viennent
et washington fournit le chinois ben si
ça vous fait rien on va régler nos
problèmes de liquidité entre asiatiques
et on va se débarrasser des états unis
d'aujourd'hui
les instruments sont en place pour
pouvoir se passer les transactions en
dollars
faut pas avoir fait de longues études
pour savoir si la masse monétaire double
aux états-unis et dé change pas en chine
va probablement dans les années qui
viennent la monnaie chinoise a monté
vis-à-vis de la monnaie américaine et
donc grosso modo il semble que s'il
était un jeune homme je touche je
suivrai le conseil d'un parent à l'est
jeune homme pour une fois je paraphrase
ray monsieur macron c'est en marche
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative en sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des choux
l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droite il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fall ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont la des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le moyen
orient
après 50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette
région complète tron était le seul à
pouvoir créer induction d'une paix
durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs le
problème est maintenant de voir comment
joe biden va traiter un sujet s'il
relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçon il est là mon les
actes et j'ai trop de dépenses trop
d'état je pense en tout cas qu'il ya
trop de bureaucratie c'est à dire un
état inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croatie
donc il faut essayer de libérer
l'économie française et notamment le
travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
n'a rien changé par exemple par rapport
à son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
21h02 paris merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi 23 février
si de variants anglais prend le dessus
le choix du confinement territoriale
aussi c'est la stratégie adoptée par le
gouvernement pour faire face à la
résurgence de l'épidémie dans certaines
parties de la france après les alpes
maritimes c'est dunkerque qui attend
l'arbitrage de l'état pour de nouvelles
restrictions
le maire propose un plan de la dernière
chance avant qu'on filme en oliviers
veron est attendu sur place demain un
rapport de force français pur qui
l'entretiennent depuis près de quatre
ans et les passes d'armes en public de
leurs présidents respectifs émaillé leur
relation altéré par des sujets sensibles
comme le cas de journalistes français
arrêté en turquie en ligne de mire aussi
du gouvernement français le gouvernement
le pardon le comportement de la diaspora
turque en france et des organisations
musulmanes lié à ankara un compromis
finalement trouvé sur les contenus
d'actualité après une bataille entre
facebook et le gouvernement australien
en cause une loi visant à réguler et des
relations entre les médias traditionnels
en difficultés financières et les géants
du net
le réseau social annonce aujourd'hui la
levée dans les prochains jours du
blocage le gouvernement ayant accepté
d'amender la loi
[Musique]
dunkerque sera donc fixé demain sur son
sort jean castex qui s'est entretenu ce
matin avec le maire de la ville du nord
demandent des mesures supplémentaires
pour freiner la propagation du virus
le taux d'incidence sur place est à 901
cas pour 100000 habitants un tour de vis
supplémentaire sera donc décidé après
une concertation avec les élus locaux et
les autorités publiques du territoire le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand est
attendu sur place demain le maire de
dunkerque proposer aujourd'hui un plan
de la dernière chance pour éviter le
confinement écouter une immense
responsabilité des dunkerquoises des
dunkerquois sur 0 rassemblement 0
regroupement ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les employeurs interdit
les réunions en présentiel dans leurs
entreprises interdisent ça veut dire
concrètement le télétravail au maximum
il s'agit aussi pour les collectivités
locales d'appeler les présidents
d'associations pour interdire pour que
les présidents d'associations
interdisent eux mêmes les conseils
d'administration les assemblées
générales et manifestations prévues dans
ces associations c'est aussi un appel à
la population pour différer les
événements familiaux les anniversaires
les retrouvailles avec les parents ce
n'est pas le moment on peut différer sa
de trois semaines ce serait cette idée
de la dernière chance avant le
confinement parce que c'est ce qui nous
attend si les dunkerquois ne respectez
pas ce type de geste très pour en parler
nous sommes avec martial béart maire ps
de grande-synthe bonsoir marc albert
merci d'être avec nous alors votre villa
il faut le préciser fait partie de cette
communauté urbaine de de dunkerque vous
êtes totalement en accord avec le maire
de la ville de dunkerque
bonsoir à tous puis effectivement on a
eu une conférence des maires ce matin où
les invités quelque peu partagé l'on a
l'habitude de travailler ensemble sur le
dunkerquois et de prendre des décisions
communes donc en plein accord avec cette
vision des choses mais aussi moi j'avais
pu donner mon opinion gt
persuadé qu'il fallait un confinement
c'est rapide et finalement vous vous
êtes laissé convaincre
il faut que le confinement soit le
dernier recours il faut laisser une
chance à la population vous êtes rallier
avec cette vision
oui on a une vision de majorité c'est
sûr mais moi mon opinion personnelle
c'est qu'on a déjà perdu beaucoup de
temps à puisque ça fait déjà plus de dix
jours que les maires de la communauté
urbaine de dunkerque avait alerté l'état
on avait demandé la fermeture des lycées
des collèges la dérogation à
l'obligation scolaire pour les
maternelles et les primaires et
malheureusement n'avait pas été entendu
par les services de l'état
donc on voit là on a perdu dix jours
aujourd'hui on a un taux d'incidence à
900 là pour cent mille et je pense qu'il
est vraiment effectivement très
important très urgent de réagir très
rapidement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous
aujourd'hui réagir qu'est ce que vous
attendez d'olivier verrons demain on
commence à entendre le ministre et le
président macron sur la théorie habitées
c'est vrai qu'il faut des mesures sur
les territoires il faut plus des mesures
nationales parce que effectivement sur
grande sur 25 sur le dunkerquois avec le
taux d'incidence il faut des mesures
spécifiques
c'est ce que nous élus de proximité on
est les premiers remparts des citoyens
on demande depuis une dizaine de jours
ça y est enfin vous avez le sentiment
que vous avez été entendu parce que ce
discours un il est pas nouveau jean
rottner l'alsacien le demandait déjà il
ya plusieurs mois plus de territorialité
idem du côté des mères enfin le
président de la république semble avoir
entendu le message
oui enfin parce qu on était quand même
un petit peu les les oublier les
abandonner et vous savez les lieux du
territoire que jeu suivant contre les
nos habitants tous les joueurs c'est
vrai que personne n'a envie d'être
confiné parce que les beaux jours
arrivent les journées se rallongent
c'est compliqué pour nos habitants puis
ça fait un an qu'ils cette pandémie lieu
perdure mais à un moment il faut raison
garder je pense qu'il faut qu'on
confiné il faut qu'ils sur des endroits
comme sur le dunkerquois où la pandémie
est important qu'on puisse avoir des
réponses spécifiques alors en tout cas
le maire de dunkerque on a entendu et 22
élus dont vous êtes à communauté de
dunkerque on dit aujourd'hui nous
voulons donner une dernière chance à la
population de ne pas être confinée ça
veut dire quoi concrètement c'est
réellement pour vous entre les mains de
la population
c'est en partie entre les mains de la
population mais c'est aussi et surtout
une décision de la part de l'état il
faut aussi renforcer les campagnes de
vaccination les campagnes de tests il
faut aussi un moment parlé à nos
habitants pour les inciter à plus de
prudence
on a de la chance voix sur grande synthe
et sur le dunkerquois en emblème des
habitants qui ont bien respecter les
protocoles sanitaires et les les gestes
barrière il faut peut-être les relances
et il faut une campagne d'information
pour sensibiliser les personnes pour
leur dire attention on est à 9 soit un
taux de l'incidence 2 901% 1000 il faut
faire attention il faut se préserver il
faut se protéger
on imagine que vous faites peut-être
référence à ce monde ces images qu'on a
vu du monde en pagaille sur sur les
digues les distances qui ne sont pas
respectées c'est quoi de l'inconscience
de l'ignorance la provocation pour vous
non je pense qu'il ya un effet ras-le
bol je vous dis ça fait un an que ça que
ça perdure mais je pense que les gens
sont plutôt sont plutôt corrects et vous
savez les clusters les plus importants
sont dans les lieux clos ce sont dans
les écoles dans les transports en commun
dans les entreprises je pense pas qu'on
plein air parlant je suis pas
épidémiologistes je suis pas médecin
mais je pense pas que c'est dans ces
réunions en plein air ça ça soit le plus
le plus dangereux effectivement
justement qu'attendez vous comme
décision concernant vos écoles dans
votre communauté
on avait demandé moi j'avais et j'avais
insisté sur le fait de football en mode
de vacances scolaires mais qu'on puisse
anticiper d'une semaine les vacances
scolaires on n'a malheureusement pas été
entendu on sait aussi que nous
sur le taux d'incidents sont à 90%
aujourd'hui de variants anglais on sait
que ses variantes qui est beaucoup peu
qui se répand beaucoup plus vite chez
les publics les plus jeunes donc je
pense qu'il fallait fermer les les
écoles beaucoup plus rapidement
aujourd'hui moi j'ai pris la décision
ici à 35 de fermer les centres de
vacances sauf pour les personnes qui
vont effectivement travailler et qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autres solutions
donc on n'accueille qu'une certaine deux
enfants j'ai pris la décision ce soir
j'avais un conseil municipal j'ai pris
la décision de le reporter parce que
pour éviter aussi les les rassemblements
trop important je pense qu'il faut
chacun y met du sien pour qu'on puisse
s'en sortir enfin est ce que vous
préconisez l'allongement des vacances
scolaires je pense qu'on fera re 1 on
refera un point d'étape dans une semaine
dans dix jours
mais effectivement si la pandémie
perdure si elles augmentent il faut
qu'on puisse prolonger le temps de
vacances scolaires moi je prends ce
aussi particulièrement aux agents des
services hospitaliers
aujourd'hui ils sont très fatigués ils
sont à saturation on a plus de place
dans nos unités
donc il fait il faut vraiment prendre
les choses en mains moi je moi je suis
très content très heureux quand
j'entends le gouvernement prendre enfin
des décisions de territoire et
interroger les élus locaux je pense que
c'est vraiment dans la concertation
qu'on va pouvoir s'en sortir
alors c'est vrai qu'en france on navigue
à vue c'est devenu même une une
stratégie de réfléchir en fonction des
chiffres est peut-être d'improviser nos
voisins vos voisins puisqu'ils sont
encore plus près de vous anglais
on t'a calendrier très définis avec une
fin des de toutes les restrictions
prévues à la fin juin est ce que on doit
les envier peut-être pas les environs
doit se remettre en question sa vie en
un seul on est frontaliers de la
belgique
aujourd'hui le gouvernement belge a
demandé à ses concitoyens de minimiser
les déplacements sur les dunkerquois est
ce que nous on doit pas réfléchir aussi
à minimiser les déplacements vers la
région lilloise vers l'ère le calaisis
pour justement ne pas faire évoluer
cette pandémie dans sur l'ensemble du
département
donc oui on a des on a des solutions de
territoire il faut aussi que sur ces
endroits comme le dunkerquois où le tome
l'incidence était très important on
puisse renforcer la vaccination
rapidement vaccinés pour que les jambes
à puisse s'en sortir effectivement merci
martiale avait un maire ps de
grande-synthe d'avoir été avec ton
direct sur rt france persia vaut le
conseil scientifique quelque peu écarté
pour les prises de décision du
gouvernement concernant la crise
sanitaire et les mesures à linverse on
vient de l'entente des élus locaux
clairement associé désormais aux
décisions pour parler de cette nouvelle
stratégie qui seront en est une
nous sommes avec alexis blanc c'est
notre rubrique les vitres ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors il
semblerait que le président macron
choisissent enfin si j'ose dire une
approche locale
mieux vaut tard que jamais
oui clairement après avoir ignoré les
élus locaux les élus des territoires
pendant des mois et même macron décide
finalement de tendre un peu l'oreille et
d'envoyer ses ministres olivier ferrand
est allé à nice ce week end jean castex
a pris le temps d'appeler l'élu de
dunkerque pour voir ce qu'il se passait
un peu en région et être au plus près du
territoire
l'idée c'est de changer de braquet c'est
vrai que cela était ignorée par la
stratégie de l'exécutif
tout se passe finalement derrière des
portes closes avec ce conseil sanitaire
ce conseil des ministres et puis
finalement plus rien et là on se rend
compte que l'exécutif va utiliser les
préfets en local veut rester maître du
tempo quand même parce que comme le
disait votre invité les élus locaux
notamment les élus du grand dunkerque
réclamait depuis plus d'une dizaine de
jours des mesures plus fortes notamment
la fermeture des écoles l'allongement
des vacances scolaires pour limiter
l'incidence bien sûr la propagation du
virus puisque il ya dix jours le taux
d'incidence c'était seulement 2 485 pour
cent mille personnes 85 cas et voilà que
nous sommes maintenant à 900 quasiment
1000 cas si la réaction avait été plus
rapide à l'elysée alors peut-être qu'on
aurait pu circonscrire le problème
il essaie de se donner la belle image
d'être dans l'action alors qu'en réalité
on est toujours un temps de retard au
niveau du gouvernement
alors alex éviter le confinement agir au
plus près des besoins en urgence est
donc clairement l'acte de la fameuse
nouvelle stratégie on est loin des
britanniques à on en parlait quelques
instants qui eux ont tout planifié
jusqu'à fin juin
oui c'est clair boris johnson a donné
des dates d'ailleurs en fonction des
commerces en fonction de la campagne de
vaccination
en fait en france tout se passe pour
faire oublier la pénurie de vaccins pour
faire comme si tout allait bien et comme
site sous suivait une courbe planifié
par
main de maître par les cabinets de
consulting mckinsey en tête et tous les
autres qui ont récupéré des milliers des
millions d'euros auprès du gouvernement
pour les conseiller dans ses stratégies
ma foi délétère de gestion de la crise
sanitaire et donc on est en train de
transformer un échec en victoire et
surtout emmanuel macron qui a repris les
commandes en disant je fais des choix
politiques
je mets les médecins loin des décisions
parce que maintenant il est question de
l'économie parce qu'on n'en parle pas
assez
quand même en 2020 c'est un français sur
six qui est passé sous le seuil de
pauvreté avec le déficit de la balance
du commerce extérieur qui ne fait
qu'empirer
sans parler bien sûr de la dette covit
donc tout se passe pour dire que tout va
pour le mieux mais il s'agit de la
communication d'ailleurs ça se voit
emmanuel macron président de la
république fait appel à des influenceurs
sur youtube mc fly et carlito leur
demandant de faire une chanson pour
rappeler les gestes barrière gabriela
talent porte parole du gouvernement qui
demain mercredi va étrenner son studio
tout neufs depuis l'elysée pour devenir
lui-même à youtube heures avec des
jeunes pour répondre aux questions des
jeunes on en est là tout est campagne de
communication tout est finalement start
up nation mais rien est dans l'action
rien n'est dans la planification rien et
dans la préparation c'est pour faire
oublier le fiasco des masques le fiasco
des tests le fiasco bien sûr des vaccins
puisqu'il n'y en a pas assez
et puis cette mesure liberticide à
incompréhensible du couvre-feu à 18
heures la france est le seul pays au
monde à avoir ce couvre-feu à 18 heures
sans parler bien sûr des confinement
alors maintenant ils sont régionaliser
locaux mais qu'est ce qu'elle qu'elle
est ce sens finalement du confinement
le week-end est ce que le virus est plus
virulent le week-end et ce qu'il est
plus dangereux le week-end non bien sûr
il s'agit simplement de dire aux gens
travailler pour le reste on s'en charge
vous restez chez vous et puis si jamais
vous tombez dans la misère on verra pour
les minima sociaux plus tard à quoi
qu'il en coûte ça aura une fin donc on
est vraiment dans un grand n'importe
quoi ou les les français ne comprennent
plus rien et c'est ce qui se passe la
séquence de communication jusqu'à
présent c'était conseil de défense le
mercredi matin à 9h conseil des
ministres dans la foulée déclarations du
porte-parole gabriela talent qui demain
fera sont une vidéo youtube
et puis son nom avait
le premier ministre castex qui faisait
une déclaration le mercredi soir et
emmanuel macron qui apparaissait une
semaine sur trois pour dire bon on a
fait un truc on va essayer autre chose
ça ne peut pas durer
les mots maintenant les éléments de
langage utilisé par la majorité
c'est pragmatisme ses stratégies ses
réalisme alors est-ce que ça va être la
suite rassure isme j'en sais rien mais
franchement on se pose des questions sur
sa stratégie alors alexis vous nous dit
tout et communication dans le même temps
il y à quelques élections à venir dont
une de taille inde en maintenant un peu
plus d'un an est ce qu'il ya une
stratégie électorale justement sur fond
de contexte de stratégies d'accès
sanitaire beh oui oui clairement alors
avant l'élection majeure c'est le dans
un an la présidentielle on a les
régionales qui doivent arriver en juin
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il est le
mac ont choisi cette stratégie de
régionalisation de la crise au-delà du
fait de diluer la responsabilité à
auprès des directeurs des responsables
de régions
les directeurs des ars non tout n'est
pas finalement centralisée
l'idée c'est d'aller séduire c'est dur
des élus locaux des élus qui eux ont le
maillage territorial que la république
en marche n'a pas parce qu'il faut
rappeler que le parti présidentiel a
fait un score calamiteux aux dernières
municipales 2 2% sait rien et l'ancrage
territorial de ce parti la république en
marche n'existe pas donc il ne faut pas
rater pour immoler macron pour avoir une
chance éventuel en 2022 la marche des
régionales alors il choisit et il s'agit
pour lui d'aller voir un peu plus loin
d'aller aussi draguer sur les terres de
la droite ou d'extrême droite
d'où ces débats qu'on a vu arriver de
nulle part sur le séparatisme sur
l'islamo gauchisme maintenant sur le
lait les cantines scolaires
histoire d'aller voir où se situe
finalement la république en marche
partie opportuniste s'il en est est
maintenant une stratégie claire aller
chercher des élus sur le terrain qu'ils
seront prêts soit faire des commissions
soit à prendre les tic est en marche
pour ces régionales
ça paraît compliqué rarement des
électeurs changeant nancy peu de deux
semaines de casaque
tous les électeurs de marine le pen qui
vont toujours préférer l'original à la
copie
donc difficile à voir difficile aussi de
voir quelle sera la sanction dans les
urnes finalement en juin pour les
régionales mais clairement cette
stratégie de gestion de crise elle est
dictée par le politique et pas par le
sanitaire d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'avait
dit le secrétaire général des nations
unies en montrant du doigt les pays qui
ont profité de cette crise sanitaire
pour mettre en place des mesures
liberticides et comment ne pas penser à
la france avec ce couvre-feu à 18 heures
avec ces autos attestation de sortie
c'est inédit
et puis la loi bien sûr sécurité globale
qui est une loi de surveillance globale
pour faire avancer l'agenda sécuritaire
de surveillance numérique
donc on est là vraiment dans un moment
crucial difficile délicat pour la
république en marche et pourrait mener
le maquereau qui voit bien que même s'il
reste à 41 % à peu près d'opinions
favorables il n'a pas trop perdu depuis
le début de la crise sans néanmoins sa
base un peu faiblir se poser des
questions sur sa capacité de commandes
et de gérer finalement un pays en crise
et donc retour aux fondamentaux de la
république en marche la communication
les vidéos youtube
on verra ce que ça donnera pour les
régionales et puis on verra pour 2022
mais c'est encore plus loin en attendant
les variants sont partout sur le
territoire et les vaccins peine encore à
arriver à ceux qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner même merci alexis poulain
éditorialistes en direct sur rt france
le haut conseil pour le climat a rendu
aujourd'hui ses observations sur le
projet de loi climat et résilience un
texte qui manque d'ambition selon
l'instance le hcc qui a vu le jour en
2010 ' fait la demande d'emmanuelle
macro et est chargée d'émettre des avis
et recommandations sur les politiques
visant à réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'hexagone dans le
cadre des objectifs de l'accord de paris
estelle farges pour les détails des
ruptures majeures pour la société
française c'est la promesse du projet de
loi climat et résilience héritage de la
convention citoyenne sur le climat
l'un des derniers textes phares du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron nos
logements notre alimentation mais aussi
nos déplacements c'est tout un ensemble
de notre vie quotidienne qui est visé
dans ce texte de 69 articles avec pour
objectif la réduction de nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'au moins 40%
en 2030 par rapport à l'année 1990 ce
texte n'a pas encore entamé son parcours
parlementaire qu'il est déjà sous le feu
des critiques
dernière en date celle émise par le haut
conseil pour le climat ce 23 février
le rapport de l'instance qui est
indépendante vise à évaluer je cite
l'ambition du projet de loi et la
pertinence de ces mesures au regard de
la stratégie nationale bas carbone une
dynamique actuelle de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre est
insuffisante c'est ce que souligne ce
rapport du hcc qui pointe aussi du doigt
le manque d'ambition et de porter des
mesures qui composent ce fameux projet
de loi ces mesures constitueraient donc
une part importante de l'effort a engagé
mais ne permettrait pas à la france de
rattraper son retard dans la transition
bas carbone
l'absence de transparence méthodologique
ne permet pas au hcc de s'exprimer sur
l'impact attendu du projet de loi
le 11 février dernier c'est le conseil
d'état qui a analysé ce texte ces
conclusions ne sont pas très tendres
avec le gouvernement l'instant s'ils
relèvent une analyse
impact trop souvent superficielle et
dénonce des insuffisances notable même
son cloche du côté de certains membres
de la commission citoyenne pour le
climat le haut conseil pour le climat
appelle donc le gouvernement à rectifier
le tir l'examen du texte par le
parlement devra permettre de compléter
et améliorer la portée des mesures
proposées y compris sur le pilotage et
la conduite de la transition pour que
les objectifs annoncés soit atteint
sachez que le projet de loi climat et
résilience arrivera donc entre les mains
des parlementaires le 8 mars prochain
l'actualité en france également marquée
par la mort de deux adolescents lors de
rixes ces dernières 24 heures dans
l'essonne le ministre de l'intérieur en
déplacement à dourdan a fait part de son
émotion
gérald darmanin qui annonce le renfort
d'une centaine de policiers et gendarmes
évoquent un phénomène très français qui
va de pair avec les réseaux sociaux un
adolescent tué à boussy saint antoine
on a donc appris ce soir et un autre
blessé à la gorge dans ces violences un
drame qui intervient au lendemain du
décès dans ce même département d'une
collégienne tué d'un coup de couteau
dans le ventre alors qu'elle
s'interposer entre deux bandes rivales
avec des jeunes de saint chéron et de
dourdan un choc pour les habitants de la
ville écouter
c'était important entre des personnes de
saint chéron et ceux de dourdan donc il
ya des personnes de 12 ans qui sont
venus à saint seurin
en bande apparemment et la gestuelle a
essayé de
de les séparer tout ça mais
et du coup il l'aurait menacée donc l
agresseur et
au final bas comme elle a persisté à
vouloir les séparer
la première vous inquiète un peu les
violences qui avaient le soir même le
soir on a peur de sortir des fois
certaines heures à ici ça va à peu près
il ya des quartiers chauds un peu plus
haut là ça s'est vraiment l'horreur
vraiment l'horreur quand on pense que
quand on pense que ces jeunes ne se
bagarrer à ce moment là surtout qu'ils
étaient à la porte
d'après ce que j'ai entendu à la radio
il était à la porte
et puis sur son ventre des gamins de
dourdan et de saint chéron et marne où
ils ont eu des altercations fille la
gamine a voulu peut-être intervenir
et puis dans la rue que c'est elle qui a
fait le coup couteau alors il se demande
pourquoi que tous et elles ont des
couteaux sur lé procureur de la
république d'evry donner une conférence
de presse cet après-midi et écouter les
investigations mettait en évidence que
les six mineurs placés en garde à vue
avait pris les transports en commun pour
venir en découdre à saint chéron
dans un contexte de rivalités entre
bandes les premières auditions ne
permettaient de retrouver l'armé du
crime
il s'agissait d'un opinel l'un des
mineurs admettez son application dans le
coup mortel porté à la victime
il est déjà connu pour deux infractions
sans lien avec des faits de violence les
qualifications retenues sont les
suivantes meurtres sur mineurs de 15 ans
violences aggravées sur mineur de 15 ans
en réunion et avec préméditation
participation à un groupement en vue de
commettre des violences non assistance à
personne en danger sur mineur de 15 ans
à lyon deux policiers ont été jugés ce
mardi pour des violences volontaires sur
un manifestant ce dernier s'était
retrouvé avec neuf d'encaisser fin 2019
après une confrontation avec les forces
de l'ordre des faits filmée et
photographiée par des témoins qui au
départ n'avait pas été consignée par la
police florian lambert
après une heure et demie d'audience le
procès d'arthur naciri est finalement
renvoyé au 28 septembre 2021
durant l'audience de nouveaux éléments
notamment d
vidéo du moment de l'affrontement sont
présentées par les avocats d'arthur
naciri manifestants qui dénoncent un
tabassage par les forces de l'ordre
ben non on est arrivés chargés et prêts
à prêt à débattre
il demande du temps et demande jusqu'au
28 septembre c'est super long et
l'enverra d'attendre bien sûr justice
réparation avec eux et que les langues
se délient un petit peu pour lionel
perrin du comité contre les violences
policières de lyon ce procès ne met pas
en cause que deux policiers de la bac
mais toute la chaîne de commandement de
la police de lyon
pour nous la l'angle d'attaqué de cette
histoire c'est le fait que s'il n'y
avait pas eu de médias n'y aurait pas eu
de procès et le fait que surtout la
hiérarchie a couvert ces faits là ça met
en cause l'ensemble de la chaîne
hiérarchique de la police à lyon et
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit c'est
concrètement ils étaient tous là il y
avait des deux chefs de la bac
il y avait un chef d'une autre unité il
y avait le commissaire qui était
responsable du service d'ordre qui
étaient ils étaient tous à moins de 10
mètres des faits et malgré ça
rien n'est sorti côté policier en
revanche les faits n'avait guère laissé
de traces le procès-verbal retraçant le
déroulement de la manifestation
mentionne le jour même une personne aux
dents cassées mais en indiquant que
l'origine de cette blessure était
ignorée arthur naciri 23 ans à l'époque
estime aujourd'hui que les coups qu'il a
reçus aurait été passé sous silence sans
une médiatisation des images sans les
vidéos à portée on aura pas de procès
d'avoir une deux une de vos vidéos qui
nous a permis de travailler dessus et
heureusement qu'elles sont là ont
heureusement qu'elles sont là et puis
j'ai même voulu porter plainte le centre
dans l'agression n'a refusé ma plainte
alors vous vous dire à quel point je
n'aurais pas pu me retrouver dans ce
palais de justice
après j'espère que la justice va faire
le rapport de l'igpn a conclu à la
responsabilité de deux policiers qui
comparaît ce mardi devant le tribunal
correctionnel en relevant que son
enquête n'avait pas permis de démontrer
le caractère intentionnel du coup porté
à la mâchoire de la victime
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les relations entre
la france et la turquie pas toujours au
beau fixe c'est moi qu'on puisse dire
l'exécutif dans sa ligne de mire le
comportement de la diaspora turque en
france puis nous parlerons du bras de
fer entre l'australie et facebook qui
s'est soldée par un compromis
aujourd'hui après un accord avec le
gouvernement
facebook va libérer des contenus
d'actualité
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
sap est une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que des gants dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
numéros uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une blague
oblique parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya
quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité la
france oubliée c'est une rencontre avec
ces citoyens qui ne se résignent pas à
la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suivrai
pas en appartement on est énervé dans le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vois des remarques ont ils pas
ceinture de tracts avec donc une grande
campagne il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe preuve était
le seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
bâle
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez en espagne
les mobilisation ne faiblit pas les
manifestants se réunissent chaque soir
depuis maintenant une semaine pour
soutenir pablo hazell ce rappeur catalan
qui a été condamné à neuf mois de prison
ferme pour apologie du terrorisme et
injures contre la couronne et
institutions d'état des rassemblements
qui se terminant en affrontements avec
la police les précisions de l'estrie
singh là notre correspondante sur place
et oui c'est la huitième manifestation
consécutive à barcelone chaque soir des
centaines de manifestants se rassemblent
pour protester contre la condamnation de
pablo hazell plusieurs magasins ont été
vandalisés des containers brûlés du
mobilier urbain arracher les des garçons
pour l'instant estimée à plus d'un
million d'euros ce qui a semé la colère
des chefs d'entreprise catalan il
explique que le futur de barcelone est
très sérieusement compromis alors
pendant les émeutes
plusieurs marques internationales ont
été visés une association de commerçants
a expliqué que ça en voilier le pire
signal aux investisseurs étrangers
alors désormais les boutiques blanc de
leur vitrine afin d'éviter un nouveau
pillage
depuis le début des émeutes 113
personnes ont été arrêtées en catalogne
dont 33 mineurs plus de 70 personnes ont
été blessées et pas moins de 90 agents
de police ont été touchés alors le
gouvernement espagnol a condamné les
violences et en parallèle il a expliqué
qu'il était
urgent de changer la loi afin d'exclure
les peines de prison car il faut le
rappeler par loisel a été condamné à
neuf mois de prison ferme pour soit 24
tweets publiés entre 2014 et 2016 et
pour une chanson concernant danse arts
et des sprays facebook et l'australie
ont trouvé un accord ce mardi le réseau
social lève le blocage des contenus
d'actualité en échange le gouvernement
australien modifie le projet de loi
visant à contraindre les géants du
numérique à rémunérer les médias pour la
reprise de leurs contenus
les explications de solenn gaudin deux
mois pour négocier
c'est le délai accordé par le
gouvernement australien à facebook et
google le but fixé contractuellement la
rémunération des médias locaux pour la
reprise de leur contenu par les
plateformes numériques
un compromis dont se satisfont les
autorités australiennes
facebook s'est engagé à entamer des
négociations de bonne foi avec les
entreprises australiennes de médias
d'information afin de conclure des
accords pour le paiement des contenus
sont des questions importantes parce que
l'objectif du projet de loi et les
intentions du gouvernement morrison ont
toujours été conçu pour soutenir le
journalisme d'intérêt public dans ce
pays un accord de dimensions colossales
les médias dont certains sont en grande
difficulté financière vont recevoir des
millions de dollars australiens de
google et facebook
en échange les géants du numérique ont
l'assurance qu'ils ne seront pas
contraints de payer des sommes plus
élevées que celles négociées avec les
organes de presse comme le prévoyait un
projet de loi examiné depuis ce lundi
par le parlement australien
ce texte avait provoqué un bras de fer
entre l'australie et les géants du
numérique jeudi dernier facebook avait
été jusqu'à bloquer la publication des
liens d'information des médias locaux
en cause les plateformes internet
redoutent que cette loi donne des idées
à d'autres pays
un blocage levé ce mardi al'annonce du
compromis
grâce à ces changements
en nous pouvons désormais travailler à
poursuivre notre investissement dans un
journalisme d'intérêt public et rétablir
dans les jours à venir les informations
sur facebook pour les australiens
le projet de loi quant à lui a été rangé
dans un tiroir
mais le gouvernement australien n'entend
pas l'abandonner au kazoo facebook et
google ne respecteraient pas leurs
engagements
l'australie n'est pas le seul pays à
avoir pris une telle initiative
le 21 janvier dernier google a signé en
france un accord-cadre avec les éditeurs
de presse basé sur le principe des
droits voisins pour une durée de trois
ans google devra négocier au cas par cas
la compensation versée aux éditeurs pour
la republication de leurs contenus
mais contrairement à l'accord australien
le compromis france elle n'assure pas
pour autant qu'une rémunération sera
obligatoirement versée et pour en parler
nous sommes avec asma mala enseignante à
sciences po spécialiste du numérique
bonsoir asma mais la merci d'être avec
nous qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur cet
accord entre l'australie et ce géant du
numérique est ce que c'est un accord
gagnant gagnant où l'australie a
finalement fait plier facebook
alors il ya deux niveaux de lecture le
premier sur la forme on pourrait croire
que c'est un accord gagnant gagnant où
les deux en fait à l'issue du bras de
fer sortent un peu la tête haute et d'un
point de vue symbolique et politique
c'est très intéressant à la séquence
politiquement est très intéressante
notamment parce qu'elle a été scrutée
par le monde entier et qu'elle vient
dans un contexte mondial où la question
de la régulation des big tech ou ce
qu'on appelle des gate keepers en fait
fait fait débat public depuis à peu près
un an y compris aux états unis et
notamment aussi en dans l'union
européenne suite à la publication du
paquet législatif en fin d'année sur le
dsl démarre donc en fait ça vient point
nommé et et s qui était très intéressant
c'était en effet ce bras de fer où tout
d'un coup on voit un état souverain qui
est capable de tenir le bras de fer et
le chantage vis-à-vis d'un big tête d'un
gatekeeper et en l'occurrence c'est
facebook google c'est un cas
ferrand parce que google a très vite et
est beaucoup plus conciliant à et à
trouver des accords en amont très
rapidement pour des histoires de modèle
économique
maintenant sur donc ça c'est vraiment
sur la forme mais ça fait jurisprudence
maintenant sur le fond c'est patent
gagnant gagnant que st est le grand
perdant de la sphère bat finalement
c'est le débat démocratique et
l'utilisateur ou le public puisque en
réalité le contenu de ceux de cette
entente fait que je je je je synthétise
très très rapidement et de façon un peu
simpliste fait que facebook a réussi
finalement à meaux à aa à aa faire un
peu penché le l'accord de façon à ce
qu'ils aient la main sur le choix des
contenus journalistiques qui est mettra
en avant en avant et donc qui pourra
rémunérés et ce qui était biaisé dès le
départ dans ce projet de loi qui est en
fait un très mauvais projet de loi sur
le fond on pourra en discuter
c'est que toute la sphère était
finalement très l'oublier aussi par le
groupe pop art murdoch news corp qui
détient deux tiers en fait de la presse
quotidienne australienne est en fait de
façon très schématique ça revenait à
demander à facebook et à google de
verser des millions de dollars
australiens au bouc murdoch qui est par
ailleurs très controversée en termes de
contenu de éditoriale et journalistique
donc de ce point de vue là
officiellement et sur la forme ou oui
tout le monde a un peu sauvé la face sur
le fond en réalité ça c'est une bombe à
retardement démocratique dont le grand
perdant bas ça sera finalement et comme
souvent dans ces cas-là l'utilisateur
final
alors est ce qu'on peut s'attendre ces
prochains temps à avoir ce type de bras
de fer entre un gouvernement et le géant
du net
ça crée un précédent
de fait et ce qui est très intéressant à
observer un peu sur l'échiquier
géopolitique mondiale c'est que c'est
plutôt les pays du commonwealth
bizarrement qui sont vraiment en pointe
donc l'australien a commencé bien que
sur le fond le projet de loi est
vraiment était vraiment très mal ficelé
et puis il ya le canada ottawa aussi qui
est en train de se pré positionnés est
qui et qui va probablement prendre le
relais dans son projet de loi pour 2021
l'union européenne c'est un peu plus
complexe parce que ce n'est pas un état
c'est une union avec beaucoup
d'hétérogénéité dans les sensibilités et
qui à tendance plutôt même si avec
l'arrivée de thierry breton n'a amorcé
un changement doctrine en termes de
régulation plus musclée des réseaux
sociaux notamment cherche encore à des
consensus beaucoup plus policé et donc
ne va certainement pas assez loin
mais l'exemple australien sur la forme
et symboliquement encore une fois créé
en effet un précédent qui pourrait être
très intéressant de suivre
alors ce compromis qu'est ce qu'il va
permettre peut-être aux médias de s'en
sortir financièrement et aussi peut-être
une meilleure information une
information de meilleure qualité
alors de fait et c'est un peu ce que ce
que je vous disais c'est à dire que la
nature de l'accord qui a été trouvé non
ne permettra pas forcément de d'avoir
une information en tout cas distribuée
sur les réseaux sociaux de meilleure
qualité d'une part par le modèle
économique initiale économie de
l'attention des algorithmes de
recommandations sur les contenus les
plus partagés etc
ça c'est l'éternel finalement débat qui
qui qui cristallise un peu les questions
de régulation
et puis surtout le projet de loi où
l'entente qui a été trouvé ces dernières
24 heures en fait
et paradoxalement renforce la position
dominante de facebook puisque lui donne
la latitude de choisir les contenus qui
va mettre en avant et donc ceux qui vont
rémunérés et ça vient dans un contexte
très australien de bras de fer entre
zuckerberg et murdoch est donc tout là
tout le discours officiel de facebook et
de dire et c'est un peu ce qu'on a
entendu dans le reportage c'est de dire
que facebook et ses plates formes là
travail d'intérêt public l'ouverture de
l'information et donc vont finalement
vouloir financer privilégié des petits
acteurs ou des petits médias locaux et
donc sous entendu pas news corp qui est
donc le grand groupe de murdoch qui est
très compliqué dans un contexte aussi du
quasi monopole de ce fameux groupe de
médias historiques traditionnelles
donc du point de vue de l'ouverture
d'information je crains que ce ne soit
pas une bonne idée
que ça n'ait pas d'effets vraiment
vertueux et que d'autre part
au contraire ça renforce finalement la
positions très dominantes de facebook et
de google aussi mais en l'occurrence de
facebook sur la distribution finalement
de l'information merci soummam à
l'enseignante à sciences po spécialiste
du numérique merci d'avoir été avec nous
les relations entre la france et la
turquie sont compliquées depuis
plusieurs mois on le sait outre les
passes d'armes en public des deux
présidents macron erdogan le contentieux
est certainement plus profond ces
derniers temps et les regards se
tournent notamment vers le comportement
de la diaspora turque en france et des
organisations musulmanes lié à ankara
les explications avec thomas bonnin
chaque occasion est bonne pour le
pouvoir turc de tacler le gouvernement
français fréquemment recep tayyip
erdogan se place en procureurs d'un
procès en islamophobie intenté contre
emmanuel macron y la loi séparatisme
adopté à l'assemblée nationale n'a fait
qu'accentuer la pression exercée depuis
ankara sur les autorités françaises
deux fédérations franco turc membre du
conseil français du culte musulman ont
ainsi refusé de signer la fameuse charte
attestant du respect des principes
républicains et vu les liens qui
existent entre ces organisations et le
pouvoir turc
certains y voient la main des rohan une
enquête parue le 6 février dernier dans
le journal du dimanche évoque d'ailleurs
une stratégie d'infiltration du pouvoir
turc en france s'appuyant sur des notes
des services de renseignement l'article
parle d'une emprise d'ankara sur la
diaspora turque
grâce à un réseau d'associations d'école
et par une présence grandissante dans la
sphère politique locale cette emprise
lui permet à la fois de disposer de
relais pour sa propagande de surveiller
les exilés et de juguler les mouvements
d'opposition plus à l'aise pour
s'exprimer dans des démocraties il veut
étouffer toute contestation dans l'oeuf
observe-t-on au ministère des affaires
étrangères une enquête alarmante à
laquelle a répondu l'ambassadeur de
turquie en france qui s'offusquent que
des éléments avancés dans l'article et
balaie ces accusations
l'avocat franco turc sel sucre demir il
s'agit d'une tentative de
déstabilisation problème c'est que la
france et la turquie malheureusement ont
des intérêts divergents et de temps à
autre on a en france dès volonté de
vouloir fragiliser la position turque en
prêtant à la turquie des choses qui
n'existent pas comme par exemple ce qui
est sous-tendue par ses articles des jdd
les tensions entre paris et ankara se
multiplient outre les propos d'erdogan
qui avait conduit à des manifestations
hostiles à emmanuel macron en turquie
les intérêts des deux pays alliés au
sein de l'otan divergent sur plusieurs
dossiers méditerranée orientale haut
karabagh syrie les points de friction
sont nombreux des oppositions géo
politique et idéologique qui participe
donc à la dégradation des relations
entre les deux pays
dernier exemple en date la décision de
l'université francophone de galatasaray
à istanbul d'imposer aux professeurs
français qui travaillent de nouveaux
critères de maîtrise de la langue turque
s'il ne conteste pas le fond les
principaux intéressés s'étonne de la
soudaineté d'une telle décision qui
pourrait remettre en cause leur séjour
dans la métropole turque
en voulant lutter en france contre le
communautarisme le gouvernement s'expose
donc aux critiques virulentes d'ankara
des liens distendus illustré par le
manque de dialogue entre les deux
présidents en arrivant au pouvoir en mai
2010 est emmanuel macron avait dû
rapidement se pencher sur l'arrestation
d'un journaliste français en turquie
près de quatre ans plus tard le dossier
turc continue de préoccuper la
diplomatie française et pour en parler
nous sommes avec alexandre del valle et
géopolitologue écrivain bonsoir
alexandre del valle merci d'être
avec nous les relations entre la france
et la turquie est ce qu'elles ont déjà
été aussi mauvaise par le passé non je
pense que l on était déjà mauvaise dans
le passé dans les années 2000 de la
ferc-cgt lalanne par rapport à mai et
aussi la reconnaissance du génocide
arménien mais ça n'a jamais été aussi
violent quand je parle de violence et
pas eu de guerre bien sûr mais dans les
mots on n'a jamais été aussi loin en
violences ce qu'a dit monsieur erdogan
contre le président macro est assez
stupéfiant entre pays soi disant amis
alliés membres de la même organisation
l'otan c'est extrêmement violent la
campagne anti française lancée par les
frères musulmans le pakistan le qatar et
la turquie contre la france a été
absolument inouïe ça a même dépassé la
violence des propos turcot officielle
contre l'autriche ou l'allemagne ou la
belgique il ya quelques années lorsque
ces pays avaient interdit des meetings
turc en faveur du référendum qui a donné
les pleins pouvoirs erdogan
non non c'est quelque chose d'inouï par
la violence des mots alors sous sarkozy
il ya eu aussi des choses équivalente
rappelez vous quand comme monsieur
erdogan en voulait à sarkozy pour la
seconde loi sur le génocide arménien des
propos avaient été assez outrancier
accusant le père de sarkozy d'avoir
participé à la légion étrangère au
génocide de plusieurs millions
d'algériens
erdogan avait juste oublié que le père
de sarkozy n'ait pas participé à la
guerre d'algérie donc y est habitué à
des propos transfert de gaz mais la jda
senti une faiblesse
il a cru que macro ont été faibles qu'il
pouvait lui taper dessus que salée
l'effrayer ça a provoqué l'effet
contraire puisque aujourd'hui comme vous
savez une chypre et la grèce remercie la
france du courage de macron qui a quand
même montré les muscles qui a envoyé des
frégates qui est l'aîné des dispositifs
militaires sous marins de ne passer par
là pour bloquer la turquie qui voulait
que pratiquement un excès les eaux
territoriales chypriote et grecque il ya
quelques mois
l'arrière
on de macron a surpris erdogan qui
croyait qu'il avait à faire un espèce de
bisounours
alain trudeau auto gentil et incapables
de réaction et il est extrêmement
surpris en deux gammes sont en gros des
rapports de force à rapport de force
entre deux hommes forts lequel a le plus
de chances de l'emporter
alors bien entendu je pense qu erdogan a
le plus de chances de l'emporter à moyen
et à long terme parce que mme erdogan a
derrière lui un peuple extrêmement
nationaliste il a muselé tous les médias
et il est capable aujourd'hui d'imposer
sa volonté il a il a vu que la force ça
marche
les rapports de force il entend
d'ailleurs assez bien avec poutine
puisque les deux se sont rendus compte
qu'il aura à faire à quelqu'un de très
têtu et de muscler et les deux
finalement s'entendre sur le partage de
la syrie ils disent souvent nous nous
entendons sur nos discorde et il
s'entend sur le fait sont pas d'accord
et du coup ils se sont départagés à
l'instar de mafieux qui se partagent
d'aider des territoires et et erdogan
sait que le système démocratique
lui-même ne permettrait pas à macro de
faire des négociations à la poutine où
on se partage tous les ans comme au 19e
siècle
il sait que structurellement les
démocraties ne peuvent pas fonctionner
comme des pays un peu plus viril ou
autoritaires ou voir des pays et
dictature des dictatoriaux donc il
compte là dessus il sait très bien que
si macron par exemple voulait jouer à
des rapports de force au sein même de sa
majorité
il y aurait des tendances dans parle
aujourd'hui service à la mode que
quelques jours les islamo gauchiste il y
en a même dans la majorité de mâcon dont
erdogan joue sur les divisions
d'ailleurs erdogan comme futile mais
aussi comme d'autres hommes forts du
monde multipolaire se disent les
démocraties sont structurellement faible
parce que le le le système des
démocraties avec les divergences
d'opinion l'instabilité les alternances
permanente permettent de faire en sorte
que on a des armes des interlocuteurs
fragile et qui ne reste pas longtemps au
pouvoir tandis que nous nous avons une
véritable politique de longue durée avec
des pouvoirs autoritaires qui peuvent
sans racines et alors nos confrères du
journal du dimanche avance que des
associations financées par l'état turc
essai de d'accroître l'influencé de la
turquie dans la société française
notamment sur la scène politique locale
et la religion est ce que ces
allégations vous semble crédible
aujourd'hui ce que l'on sait c'est que
il y a deux grands pôles qui essaie
d'instrumentaliser l'islam de france et
d' instrumentaliser la religion en
saveurs d'agenda impérialistes
irrédentistes islamistes c'est
premièrement les frères musulmans
structure par rapport au sommet mondial
aujourd'hui également que c'est dans ta
et ceux qui travaillent et travaillent
étroitement avec les frères musulmans
et bien c'est les réseaux islamistes
turcs qui jadis était séparé du
politique à l'époque du kémalisme et qui
depuis hier de galles sont repris en
main par l'islam d'état qui je répète
pendant longtemps l'islam d'état turque
et était contre l'islamisme turc y avait
une énorme confrontation entre les deux
erdogan a réuni les instruments fille
ciel des réseaux des mosquées et des
associations islamistes turcs en europe
1 qui aujourd'hui sont repris en main
par le diamètre
le ministère turc e d'ivoire région et
consulaires qui gère les mosquées en
france mais ça me dit il
sans parler d'autres associations
islamistes assez radicales comme les
milli gorus le milieu lui c'est
l'association originel de l'islam
politique turque d'ailleurs dont vient
monsieur erdogan et son mentor erbakan
donc il ya aujourd'hui une véritable
instrumentalisation du religieux pour
faire de l'ingérence politique
pourquoi il faut se mettre à la place
des arts doghouse malin s'ils décident
et turcs ne s'intègrent pas qu'il serait
islamisme et et qu'ils adhèrent à
l'islam en nationalisme d'erdogan
ils vont moins s'intégrer ils vont
garder la nationalité turque et ils vont
voter c'est une réserve des lecteurs
énorme
et hier dogan c'est que si un électeur
turc né en france et son fils
s'intègrent et deviennent laïque et bien
ils ne voteront pas pour rire de gamme
par contre si grâce à la parano là parce
que j'appelle la stratégie de par
anodisation en faisant croire que les
français persécutent les turcs et
musulmans
si on arrive à resserrer les liens des
communautés dans un an
logique séparatiste quand même justement
des macros et bien ces gens vont rester
en quelque sorte endogame vont par
s'intégrer et ils vont continuer à être
une réserve des lecteurs pour erdogan il
faut savoir qu'il ya 4 millions il ya
une réserve des lecteurs pour erdogan de
4 millions en dehors de la turquie dont
3 ou 4 millions entre la france la
belgique le nord de l'europe et
l'allemagne
c'est une c ça peut faire la différence
dans une élection cet exemple est plutôt
électoraliste dans cette attitude
agressive 1-2 d'erdogan
c'est l'avenir les relations ne
s'arrangeaient pas parce que vous les
avez décrite très mauvaises entre la
france et la turquie est ce que ça
pourrait remettre en cause selon vous le
fonctionnement de l'otan je pense
qu'aujourd'hui là aussi erdogan a été
choqué il a fait celui qui était choqué
lorsque macron a dit que le temps était
en mort cérébrale
mais on le sait depuis la première et
même natte et surtout la deuxième guerre
du golfe en irak donc c'est à dire
depuis 2000 des années le début des
années 2000 déjà george bush père et
ensuite fils avaient été choqués du
manque de solidarité de la turquie lors
des guerres en irak pour une raison
logique d'ailleurs un tour pour les
turcs on a déstabilisé le moyen-orient
et on a réveillé le séparatisme kurde en
irak est aujourd'hui maintenant syrie et
donc indirectement aussi en turquie
donc il y a une une perception mutuelle
négative extrêmement forte entre les
deux pays en gros pour la turquie
l'otan déstabilise la turquie en
réveillant et l'irrédentisme kurdes au
moyen-orient et de l'autre côté pour
l'europe la turquie est un prédateur un
état impérialiste qui étend des réseaux
néo ottoman pour conquérir à la fois des
pays arabes se plaît d'ailleurs beaucoup
aux égyptiens aux émirats et c est pour
s'emparer du gaz en méditerranée
orientale qui est aussi une pierre
d'achoppement avec nous puisqu'on a des
intérêts pétroliers aussi en
méditerranée orientale comme aussi les
grecs ne supprime aussi les italiens
avec lenny nous voyez on a plein de
dossiers d'affrontements à la fois
religieux politiques historiques gazier
énergétique et bien sûr le contrôle de
la libye
1ce ce que va devenir la libye dans le
futur la nature qui essaient de profiter
de la guerre civile ni viennent pour
s'emparer aussi
pétrole onshore en libye en plus de gaz
offshore en méditerranée et partout dans
ces pourrait rajouter aussi le haut
karabakh de la france et la turquie sont
en désaccord total sur tout mais aussi
la france et l'otan depuis au moins 20
ans l'otan voit la turquie comme un
véritable cauchemar parce qu'on ne sait
pas comment expulser et la turquie
possède 50 missiles nucléaires
américains sur son sol
comment faire à un pays qui a la plus
grande armée de l'otan terrestre le plus
grand nombre de soldats mais qui abrite
aussi du matériel nucléaire de l'otan et
des américains c'est pas un pays dont on
peut se débarrasser comme ça ou vous
expulse de l'otan pratiquement tous les
membres de l'otan aimerait que la
turquie n'en fasse plus partie mais on
ne sait pas comment revenir en arrière
on a donné à la turquie un pouvoir de
nuisance gigantesque au dans le cadre
des armements de l'otan qu'elle abrite
sur son sol et qu'elle pourrait ne pas
rendre si facilement qu'on le voudrait
merci beaucoup alexandre del valle
géopolitologue écrivain pour cette
analyse merci à vous et c'est la fin de
cette édition prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
emilie gogh h
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]